it all comes to fruition at the end baby
and when it does you're gonna be like f
yeah man you're gonna be like yeah this
is what I'm talking about this is the
prime I want to see
what's up guys this is gonna be my
review of Transformers rise of the Beast
this is going to be a non-spoiler and
spoiler review now what do I mean by
that very simple the first portion of
this video will be non-spoiler I will
let you guys know in ample time when
we're going to get into spoiler
territory so at that time you can turn
off the video or watch something else or
you can continue to watch it's up to you
so I did want to let you guys know that
but this first portion will be
non-spoiler also full disclosure I was
the host of the world premiere here in
Singapore for Transformers rise of the
Beast so I was doing the press
conference the red carpet and the
screening so
um if you guys think I'm biased to this
that's up to you but I'm giving you my
non-biased opinion all right so let's
get down to talking about this film what
do I think of it it is one of the better
Transformer movies we have seen out of
the seven made thus far it's right up
there with bumblebee in my personal
opinion it's got the heart of Bumblebee
but yet it's got the action that we want
to see out of a transformer movie but
it's not convoluted action it's not
action that doesn't make sense it's not
over the top it really fits into the
ethos of the Transformers that you grew
up with this series like I I did I was a
G1 baby I grew up with that GI Joe
He-Man after school weekly that was my
jam this movie brought a smile to my
face so when I walked out of the theater
I was smiling from ear to ear going
Stephen cable Jr he's a fan you can
totally tell by his direction of the
film and fans are going to love this
film for what it brings it's not a
perfect film there are some things that
could be improved like any movie out
there but there are way more positives
than negatives and I think a lot of you
out there who are on the forums who are
you know hearing tidbits or hearing
rumors out there just hearing Snippets
of the film but don't understand the
context once you see the film in its
entirety it will make a lot more sense
to you and I think a lot of you out
there gonna be like that was fun that
was a really fun ride and June is a
packed month for movies we've got
Transformers we've got flash Little
Mermaid's already out oppenheimer's
coming out Mission Impossible there's a
ton of films coming out
I definitely think you're going to enjoy
Transformers amongst the chaos of movies
coming out in gym okay so let's get down
to talking about this uh the cast
Anthony Ramos plays Noah Diaz who's a
private in the OR was a private in the
US Army that kind of ties in towards the
end of the film which we'll talk about
later on and he's out of the military
this time he is trying to help his mom
and his younger brother who has a
medical condition he's trying to help
get a job you know help contribute to
the family having a rough go at it had a
little bit of a tough time in the
military and his previous record is
coming back to haunt him in a way so
he has to find a way to make money so he
tries to take the easy way out and
that's when we're introduced to Mirage
and uh this is played by Pete Davidson
her voice by Pete Davidson and you see
some of the scenes in the trailer when
from when they first meets and I'm going
to tell you this relationship sells the
movie Anthony Ramos plays Noah Diaz
perfectly he's a fantastic actor this
guy is talented as hell I mean he's in
the Heights he was in you know he was in
Hamilton this guy's this guy's legit he
brings uh a certain
Persona to the Transformers Universe we
have not seen before but in a way it
feels very relatable and very grounded
and this guy's just gonna knock it out
of the parking he does in this movie all
right but his relationship with Mirage
and Pete Davidson is
freaking amazing it's right up there
with with Haley Steinfeld and Bumblebee
it's right up there with them it is
there's heart to it there's humor to it
and Pete Davidson look I don't know much
about Pete Davidson to be honest with
you I mean I obviously know he's a
comedian but I know more of who he hooks
up with more than I know of his work and
as Mirage and how he voiced this
character and the personality that he
brought to the table
honestly it's one of the better
performances we have seen in
Transformers we're not getting into
Peter Cullen territory okay
he's the God he is the goat but in terms
of the human and Transformer interaction
Mirage is up there with some of the best
it's fantastic and I think a lot of you
out there when you watch this film
You're gonna laugh you're gonna get some
tears in your eye you're gonna smile I
mean not all the jokes work okay but
it's not corny like it was in the bay
verse we're not going to see vending
machines turn into Transformers talking
it ain't that kind of movie and he
brings it it's really really cool to see
plus he's a Porsche so it works up RS3
awesome car you know very rare to car
too all right
um but then they kind of go on to this
journey then they meet the other
Autobots coming into play but this is
where to point in the Transformers lore
where the Autobots don't necessarily
interact with humans now bumblebee did
of course but Prime is not and the
others have not so there is a little bit
of mistrust happening into this play
which is nice and it's interesting
because the humans don't necessarily
trust the Transformers and vice versa
and Prime is a very kind of different
Prime than what we're used to seeing
Prime is still the leader he's still I'm
Optimus Prime and all that kind of stuff
but there's a bit of cynicism in his in
his personality he's not trusting the
humans he doesn't know if he can trust
them and it's fascinating what they do
with prime because they kind of fleshed
him out a little bit more which is
really nice to see because in the babers
it was always like I'm Optimus Prime I
wanted to do this I'm Optimus Prime
because he kept talking him about
himself in third person you're like dude
like is the writing that bad that you
guys can't write him correctly let me
tell you this film he's written a lot
better Peter Cohen's voice his
characterization of prime
it's guys you're gonna like it you're
gonna be sometimes you might question
some of the way they did Prime and like
in the way that he reacts to certain
things but
it all comes to fruition at the end baby
and when it does you're gonna be like f
yeah man you're gonna be like yeah this
is what I'm talking about this is the
prime I want to see you can tell I was a
fan
and I really liked what they did with
him and they were introduced to Elena
Wallace played by Dominic Fishback this
girl brings some gravitas to the film
now we're not going to get the Megan Fox
kind of uh characterization that we were
used to sing in a lot of the bay verse
films of the females where they have
these really big titles but they
actually do nothing but just blow their
hair in the wind and look really awesome
and really sexy Dominic brings a very
much a character-driven performance to
this which I think a lot of people are
going to enjoy she's a talented actress
she has been a nominated Productions
before and uh this woman really has some
acting chops and it shows in this and as
her with her and Anthony Ramos together
on this journey there's a great
chemistry there both New Yorkers so
you're getting a little bit of that East
Coast vibe to it but at the same time
you believe her that actually she knows
these things and that actually she is
good at what she does versus some of the
previous
um female iterations of the babers where
you they're supposed to be this
fantastic scientist or supposed to be a
know it all in this Arena but they don't
do much at all except look really good
but you're not going to get that kind of
characterization in this film Dominic
Fishback now she is a museum researcher
sort of an intern there and she
discovers this sort of this old ancient
bird with some hieroglyphics on the
chest but nobody can understand what
language it's from so she does some
research and realizes it's not from of
this world or is it but it kind of comes
from a tribe she believes or some part
of a tribe in Peru and then all of a
sudden boom that's part of the MacGuffin
the terracon's come into play and it's
like a hoo hoo ha big battle the
beginning of the film and then you
realize how badass the terracons
actually are and that's when we're
introduced to Scourge voiced by Peter
Dinklage and Peter Dinklage has got a
fantastic voice as it is and he's a
great actor and he just brings a
gravitas and fear from Scourge that
makes you go he's even more badass than
Megatron I kind of feel like Scourge is
one where I'm like
this guy is ruthless man and I'll be
honest with you some of the action in
here is pretty brutal like it's at the
level where you're like okay all right
damn I was expecting that one and as we
go throughout this journey I mean
obviously they have to go to find you
know find out this other portion of the
McGuffin because unicron's after it
because Unicron needs this so we can
destroy any planet in the galaxy and he
can travel to any planet in the galaxy
it's kind of like his time travel or his
sort of like warp speed device I don't
know it is what it is but
um and it works in this film for the
most part it does work because the human
relationship and the other subplots that
come into play really sort of support
this and then kind of ground you in this
world of Fantastical Whimsical robots
turning into cars and planes and all
that kind of stuff and yeah so it works
uh but anyway that's where we go to Peru
that's when we meet the maximals optical
course Optimus primal and air razor and
cheetor and rhinox Etc et cetera and the
maximals are badass man they're really
cool and I know a lot of you Beast War
fans out there I know the timelines are
a little bit different from G1 to Beast
Wars I get it they do sort of explain it
in this film a little bit they kind of
give you a hint at least and that comes
from Air razor voiced by Michelle yo
they don't dive deep into that lore but
I have a feeling they may in future
films if they want to because there's a
lot of Rich history there and I think
that that might be very exciting and
very cool for the fans to see but they
do touch on a little bit of that in case
you're wondering Michelle yo is a
fantastic voice actress for this um I
mean she's done animated movies and
films before in series and so she's
great and she brings a gravitas to air
razor along with Ron Perlman as Optimus
primal where it just works now Chi tour
and rhinox are
there's not much of them in the film
they're there but there's no sort of
character development in it so you're
really going to be I mean if you're
looking for that I know some of you guys
are fans of them maybe in future films
they'll bring that into play but I mean
there's so many characters in this film
anyway they've got to flesh out from the
humans to the Transformers to the
Autobox the terracons you gotta like you
gotta figure out who's gonna get what on
screen and so it makes more sense the
way they did it this way but I'm sure
fans will want more as they always do
anyway and that's where you find out
where Optimus primal actually sort of
bridges that relationship from the
Transformers and the humans in a very
interesting way and it's kind of cool
how they how they bring it into fold and
it also adds a sort of humanity to
Primal and a sort of warmth to him where
he's just a beast pun intended but it
does work
um then of course we build up to the
third and final Act which looks you've
seen some of that in the trailer already
which looks like Avengers end game you
know and unicron's coming in what are
they gonna do and how are they gonna
battle this and they're beating Scourge
and then they're if I didn't discouraged
and then terracons and the you know it's
just going full on out you know I mean
it is badass but the cool thing about
the battle scenes as that as in any
point in time you know who is who unlike
the bay verse where all the Autobots and
Decepticons kind of look alike like they
are very different in this film very
different in terms of design Aesthetics
is G1 but modernized but you still know
who is who the personalities are
distinct enough so you know who is who
and it flows beautifully and then also
you see the humans come into play for
this battle and it makes sense there is
one portion I'll talk about in the
spoiler version of this film which kind
of is the first time we're seeing it in
live action and it works beautifully I
won't tell you exactly how it comes into
play but I'll let you know what it is
anyway so overall
this is setting up to be a very
interesting uh series of Transformer
films very different from what we saw
from the bay verse there are some bass
specs to this film in terms of the
action some of you are going to see look
at like yeah I could see some of that
looking like a Michael Bay film but it
does set up for a very interesting
series of film and I like that there we
have fans now helming this and I think
Stephen cable Jr may be back for the
third one the way they were talking at
the press conference and the way they
were hinting at things he may already be
signed on and I hope he is because he is
a fan and for you fans out there we are
going to be in good hands let me just
say that all right so that's it for the
non-spoiler version of this film check
it out I think you're going to enjoy it
even if you're not a huge fan of
Transformers there's a lot of fun
there's a lot of heart and there's a lot
of humor and you are going to really
enjoy where they went with this I think
you are so that's it now let's get into
spoiler territor but before we do here's
a quick message from our sponsor
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of four men function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
alright guys so let's talk spoilers as
many of you have already heard the
ending of this film involves the
introduction to GI Joe how does this
come into play does it make any sense is
it really cheesy or corny and to answer
the latter no it's not cheesy or corny
it's actually kind of cool how they did
it you do not see any of the GI Joe uh
Team involved in this all you see is a
business card with the GI Joe logo on it
and it's brought in by a gentleman who's
interviewing Noah Diaz for a job at the
very end of this film because he still
needs to get work you know he's not
going to get paid for saving the world
because he's with the Transformers right
and uh the way that they kind of hint at
it where he's talking about that he was
out of town for a little bit he's been
doing some work overseas and and they
say yes we know about your work in Peru
and he's like I didn't tell you that and
they're like you didn't need to and then
they start kind of unveiling other
things that about no ideas that he's
never told people and then they really
you find out they've actually been
watching him and the fact that he has
very very influential friends now
they're interested to work with him and
that's where we get introduced to the
um GI Joe aspect where they give him a
business card and say let us know what
you think and we'd love to have you on
board and in these doors in this sort of
Warehouse open up and there is you see
these futuristic kind of modern planes
and different military-grade equipment
you're like oh okay welcome to the world
of GI Joe and that's where the movie
cuts off at that point in time so it's
done very Tastefully and I don't know if
it's going to tie into Snake Eyes I
didn't ask that question because Snake
Eyes obviously didn't do that well at
the box office unfortunately uh and uh I
don't know what's consigned to the other
GI Joe films or if it's going to be a
fresh reboot they did not tell us that
but they did say that the next film will
be
um definitely having GI Joe in it so
yeah this would be very very cool and it
was um you heard the gasps in the
audience when it happens like it was
like what
what like whoa and a lot of is actually
very positive in the sense where fans
are in the audience going whoa that is
cool because it's done Tastefully also
another little bit of a spoiler is you
this is the first time we're seeing the
exo suit come into play in live action
for a Transformers film and how they
bring it into play is really awesome
this portion I do not want to give away
because it's kind of heartwarming and uh
yeah I was kind of touching how it came
up and it was cool and uh yeah Anthony
Ramos sold that one a hundred percent
I'll just say it involves a little bit
of Mirage so with that guys those are it
for spoilers and if you like this
Transformer review let us know in the
comment section below any questions you
have I'll try to answer those for you
and if you like this video check out
more of our reviews right here